on one of our videos choice an actor or
left a comment and this actor put I
don't know how to find work and an agent
won't work with me because I don't have
experience what would you tell this
actor pursue a manager because it seems
like nowadays they're easier to gain but
you know it's not like how it used to be
it used to be you get a manager you get
an agent then you go out your audition
and stuff no you can do a lot of it
yourself you can build your body of work
by submitting and creating content you
know actors have this tendency of just
waiting around and you know why or if
they get an agent a manager oh ok
everything's ok no it's not you know
agents and managers are like gosh the
last person they see is the last person
they remember so if they met you five
people ago or five persons ago now
they're not even thinking about you and
you have to stay in their mind you can
do so much more nowadays especially
being non-union because there's a lot of
projects that are non-union actors tend
to get caught up in this thing up my
career is not going anywhere unless I'm
doing it but you know it goes back to
that money thing again they get into it
to make money and the money is not the
key you know you can make money doing a
lot of other things if you're if you're
in the entertainment industry
specifically acting you're in it in
order to live your dream you're in it in
order to create great content it's gonna
change life that's just my opinion but I
would I would top it off a capital off
by saying create your own content
because you can even become sag that way
or sag eligible that way or submit
submit submit submit yourself for
anything and everything
find out who the casting directors on
projects let them know hey listen I'm
here I'm available to do standing work
I'm available to do extra work because I
started out as an extractor and it
opened up doors for me the first extra
gig that I got I got camera time I
didn't get any voice work but the camera
was on me
over and over again so there were little
signs that told me to keep going and
that's what I would say to anybody who's
an actor it's like don't just depend on
getting an agent or a manager you got
your own resources the internet now is a
hive of different types of resources to
submit yourself there's so many casting
type of opportunities you know yeah
listen you may not become the leader of
a film but at least you get in next to
the person next to the person what's
wrong with that I'm talking about
observation it's a great great way to
observe how the set works the feel of it
you know that the protocol you can see a
lot extra work background actors
whatever you want to call it my first
job on the set as an extra was free Jack
and I got to meet Emilio Estevez and
Rene Russo it doesn't get any better in
Atlanta we were we were there we were
there it was the best weekend ever we
were there for the Prince concert and
after that we riding by and we saw this
area we're like what's all this
happening here
and so we went over to the area where
the video village was now even know how
we got over there we just parked and
walked over there and I'm asking this
guy like what's going on they're filming
a movie with Anthony Hopkins and Rene
Russo and Amelia I wasn't like really it
was like yeah and I'm like well what's
that lady doing
he says she's looking for extras and I'm
like what's an extra or you get to be in
a movie
so I didn't know the the particular is
for it but I just knew all this is
something cool and so I go over and and
they said just stand there and look good
cuz she'll pick you so she comes and
picks me and my friends and we're in
this movie and this is before I come out
to LA and do what I consider my first
first extra work which I knew what
exactly I was doing but when I'm at this
is car that keeps going back and forth
and they put us right there out pops out
when they Russo I pops out give me
Estevez we're standing there we're
talking we're having a good time we take
pictures Emilio and I are singing hair
song
songs from here it's crazy and I'm like
this is cool this is great I get to LA I
do my first big extra job as I said
before and it gets to a point where I
need to become sag and I'm like man how
am I gonna do it I need now is I go look
at my box guess what that voucher that I
had got from FreeJack was a SAG eligible
voter so I had been tap hardly not even
oh wait oh my gosh and that's just from
driving by not calling driving by a
casting didn't know anything about it
talk about random fortune stroke you
know got out ran over applied yourself
and that's what I think people should do
I think you should apply yourself don't
be afraid to do extra work sometimes if
it's meant to be for you you may even
get a line you know managers and ages
can't do that for you
you